tell your husband to stop telling his
football glory story that's what happens
you watch the game you're like it
reminds me dadbod you're sitting on the
couch good morning everybody
morning glad there are a few stories we
think you'll be talking about today the
Louisiana State University Tigers are
college football's national champs
burroughs got time launching for the
edge
amazing that touchdown pass from LSU
quarterback John burrows sealed last
night's 42 to 25 victory over Clemson at
the New Orleans Superdome
furro became the first B major college
quarterback to throw get this guy's 66 0
TD passes in a season
LSU finished a season undefeated it is
their first national title since oh
seven but when I first thought though I
thought I Jenna Gibson on our team Joe
bro there's something very irresistible
about him
small-town Ohio yeah sitting on the
bench at Ohio State they didn't want him
on the field and now look at him now I
believe he said records for in the title
game for passing yards and TVs amazing
numbers amazing statistics and since
like genetics guy and he seems like a
really nice today that we're working for
we like everybody you know we like also
Joe burrow be an amazing record setter
you